[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire gersoise aujourd'hui michel
guérin qui a fait toute sa carrière dans
le contre espionnage français
il a été sous-directeur de la dst
directeur central adjoint de la ddt et
série inspecteur général de la dg si il
publie chez mareuil à un dictionnaire
renseigner de l'espionnage bonjour
michel guérin pour un pour un
professionnel de la sécurité intérieure
comme vous quelle est la différence
entre un espion et un journaliste elle a
écouté ça commence warba les deux vont
chercher de l'information non on va dire
que peut-être la finalité n'est pas la
même au delà des moyens qu'ils utilisent
pour avoir cette information c'est à
dire que les journalistes ses buts
voilà une information on va dire qu'un
officier de renseignement c'est un moyen
un moyen après de progresser pour faire
d'autres actions ou de notre analyse
et puis l'information ça se travaille
aussi c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça un
renseignement
il ya pham xuan anne qui figure dans
votre dictionnaire renseigner de
l'espionnage qui était un journaliste
sud vietnamien qui s'est révélé être en
réalité un un espion du vietnam du nord
communiste à l'époque et il lui disait
que au fond la différence était que le
journaliste une fois qu'ils obtenaient
la formation il a publié alors que
l'espion une fois qu'il obtient
l'information il la cache
oui ben c'est ça ça veut dire la même
chose c'est-à-dire que dès qu'il a en
formation au chant dit cela publie c'est
le but quand même hein voilà
alors que l'officier de renseignement
utiliser cette information ne la publie
pas bien sûr et l'a fait rentrer dans
d'autres informations d'autres
renseignements pour pouvoir se
reproduire une analyse soit 1
renseignements qu'on dira bien bien bien
enveloppé dans ce cas julian assange
c'est bien un journaliste ce n'est pas
un espion
il a publié toutes les informations y
compris les secrets d'état ou télé il
est il a eu accès mais mais ce n'est
absolument pas un espion avance ce n'est
pas mon bonbon et appelez ça comme vous
voulez un bon lanceur barrières tout bon
quelqu'un qui a peut-être voulu qu'on
leur parle de lui ça existe aussi mais
non non ce n'est pas un espion bien sûr
et un agent
c'est quoi un agent à ans l'agent si
vous voulez c'est un terme un peu dévoyé
on le met à toutes les sauces il y a
des agents de renseignement d argent
double des agents infiltrés enfin toutes
sortes d'agents
il ya également des agents de police
n'ont alors un agent en termes
professionnels
c'est quelqu'un qui goûte et pour donner
de l'information un officier dans cette
voie là d'accord donc jacques seconde
n'est pas un agent james bond à être une
belle agents ils recrutent des agents
absolument oui c'est un officier de
renseignement lui ai alors il ya le
homard au mont d'or ouais le mot
barbouzes qui figure dans votre
dictionnaire les barbouzes
vous dites que c'est emblématique du
mépris en fait dans lequel les français
tiennent les services de renseignement
ou les a appelés les barbouzes parce que
sans doute dites vous parce qu on
imaginer qu'ils mettaient des fausses
barbes oui alors là ah bon c'est un
sujet effectivement assez assez profonds
le renseignement bon c'est pas tellement
dans la mentalité française bon c'est
quelque chose qui a un peu
décrié qui est toujours présenté sous
une forme un tout petit peu péjorative
d'ailleurs lorsqu'on dix espions tout de
suite on parle on pense à marc vous
voilà alors ils barbouzes je vous
rappelle le terme d'art blues était un
terme qui est apparu au xxème siècle qui
vient de barbes 1 et c'est un terme
qu'on a employé pour désigner
ce
service non officielles qui avaient été
créés pendant la guerre d'algérie pour
lutter contre les os en employant les
mêmes moyens que voilà donc des moyens
l'idée godon officiel et c'est donc on
appelait ça i bar blues et puis c'est
venu dans langue française après il est
un film mais entendu avec des excréments
célèbre qui synthétise et donc voilà
c'est parti
francis blanc gino ventura bernard blier
francis blanche
enfin voilà ils étaient tous
pratiquement mireille darc il faut pas
oublier voilà donc depuis en france
espion c'est assimilé à barberousse et
avec cet aspect péjoratif
je vous rappelle une phrase d'audiard
donnant un bon un barbu c'est un barbu
trois barbus et du bar blues
voilà c'est dans l'âme entités
françaises et mais justement c'est ça
qui est intéressant
cette mentalité française à l'égard de
l'espionnage et qu'on voit bien ce film
est emblématique
chaque fois que les français pendant
très longtemps on fait des films sur
l'espionnage c'était toujours des
parodies des pastiches des comédies au
fond il ya le monocle noir il ya le il
ya leur le grand blond avec une
chaussure noire il y as évident alors
oui il ya oss 117 le caire nid d'espions
il faut vraiment qu'on est con ne
prennent pas ça au sérieux l'espionnage
pur d'eau seulement pour lui consacrer
uniquement des comédies et des
pesticides mais aussi pour croire que es
s c'était un service français tout le
monde sait quand on s'intéresse à
l'histoire du renseignement que oss est
un service américain
mais les français l'ignorant on a
baptisé notre espion nationale on l'a
baptisé oss 117 au cinéma parce que dans
les romans jean bruce lui savait très
bien que son son hub herbe une histoire
de la bad travaillait pour les services
américains
mais les français eux l'ignorent oui oui
totalement totalement oss est un service
terry pendant la guerre par les
américains
pour éviter un peu les britanniques
c'est donc un service de renseignement
qui avait une action extrêmement
importante dans les opérations
clandestines et ces sabotages et autres
bons d'ailleurs qu'il a été supprimée
dès la fin de la guerre
voilà mais sa série américain où il 100%
bien sûr mais comment l'expliquez-vous
pourquoi expliquer comment expliquez
vous que les français n'aient jamais
pris ça au sérieux est ce que c'est
parce que je me suis dit que c'était
peut-être parce qu'au départ c'était
surtout des militaires au fond en france
à la différence des britanniques par
exemple
alors écoutez ça c'est une très bonne
question pourquoi on en est là en france
alors il ya tout un tas de raisons donc
je pense que bon on n'aura pas le temps
de tous les deux tout les évoquer
d'autant plus que bon tout le monde
n'est pas forcément d'accord on peut
dire que alors qu'en fait il ya une
tradition française
il ya eu dans live world et oui on va y
revenir peut-être oui on va et revient
avec le sait voilà absolument tout à
fait alors pourquoi alors déjà il ya
peut-être une chose effectivement
l'origine sanitaire puisqu'à l'origine
l'espionnage c'était pour
c'était au profit c'est au fil des gens
qui se battaient désarmés et cetera
depuis l'antiquité depuis des temps
immémoriaux donc et en france si vous
voulez la mentalité
les militaires c'est le panache bon
l'histoire de france est peuplé de
charges glorieuse de
pendant la guerre l'italie la fureur
prendra francese voilà en 14 on est
partis baïonnette au canon et puis on a
vu ce que ça a donné
donc cette panache or si vous voulez le
l'espionnage c'est un métier de long
c'est un métier où on se montre pas il
n'y a pas de panache dans et je fais
toujours si vous voulez ce parallèle
parce qu'il me semble assez intéressant
avec les ninjas bon in i jah qui
s'appelait d'ailleurs les shinobi au
japon les guerriers les bougies
suivez le code du bushido il fallait il
fallait se montrer courageux il fallait
aller au contact
alors que le média pour eux sans
apporter la mission voilà s'agissait pas
de se montrer au contraire leur leurs
deux mots clés c'était furtivité
discrétion et efficacité voilà les
randonnées un peu là donc effectivement
en france comme c'était bon c'était
pascal durieux et ben voila je sais pas
ce n'est pas tellement la culture après
au cours de l'histoire il ya des
affaires malheureuse qu'on a mis qu'on
est bien avant que l'affairé dreyfus etc
et c'est vrai qu'en france lorsqu'on
parle de l'espionnage ou du
renseignement d'ailleurs si vous voulez
prendre à tout à l'heure pour quoi
avancer mes propos et espionnage ben
parce que parce que chaque fois on met
en avant bad et on va dire des affaires
malheureusement j'ai l'impression que
c'est un peu changé depuis la série le
bureau des légendes la célèbre série
d'eric rochant pour la première fois on
a eu un français qui a fait un travail
sérieux sur le sur les renseignements et
sur les renseignements français parce
que j'en avais déjà fait un très beau
film là-dessus
les patriotes mais c'était les gens du
mossad là c'est l'airé le renseignement
français et tout à coup on y croit et
tout à coup et tout à coup ça marche je
me suis dit est-ce que ça n'est pas
l'affluence du terrorisme là où tout à
coup avec le terrorisme la lutte contre
le terrorisme les français ont bien
compris que le seul moyen est le
meilleur moyen en tous cas lutter contre
le terrorisme c'était le renseignement
et tout à coup on prend ça au sérieux
aurait coûté déjà pour le terrorisme
bon je peux aider un peu faut quand même
savoir que l'on a été malheureusement un
peu précurseur parce que la france a été
un des communiqués pays touchés dans les
années 90 et on s'était intéressé alors
le terrorisme en général bien sûr mais
le tourisme dont on parle à l'heure
actuelle c'est est ce qu'on appelle le
terrorisme djihadiste bon à l'époque on
appelait ça des moudjahidine et peu
importe donc on a eu
nous on a travaillé espérons en amont
par rapport à d'autres pays à d'autres
services
et là pour le coup on a eu une vraie
culture parce que si tout le monde a
découvert que le tourisme existait grand
septembre 2001 ou quand même savoir que
entre temps le dernière temps en france
c'était pour royal 1,96 de port royal où
en 2001 j'ai puis plus tard jusqu'à
fermera il n'y a pas eu d'attentât en
france quoi parce qu'on les a tous
éviter tout simplement donc
effectivement le travail des services
français
au niveau du contreterrorisme a été très
important et le bureau des légendes
écoutez le
la question n'est pas de savoir si c'est
kelly parquet libre etc
c'est pas le sujet c'est l'impact que ça
et effectivement c'est un impact
extrêmement positif
les gens voient ça on a l'impression que
voilà que c'est pénible c'est sans doute
très bien fait c'est ce qu'on me dit et
donc voilà donc effectivement la notion
d' espionnage est en train petit à petit
de changer dans notre pays ça va pas se
faire du jour au lendemain mais ça
évolue
il faut savoir par exemple au niveau des
études académiques
bon on a eu un retard énorme énorme les
tous les to tous les aspects
scientifiques et cetera sont anglo
saxons américains en particulier et nous
on a mis le train un peu en retard
alors ça progresse on a d'excellents
chercheurs qui font du très bon travail
petit à petit
les études académiques remonte en france
au niveau de renseignement et au niveau
de la perception
les équipements le bourreau des légendes
et quelque chose d'absolument un succès
total alors il ya deux pays en revanche
qu'ils ont une très longue culture du
renseignement de l'espionnage c'est la
grande bretagne et la russie
vous expliquez pourquoi d'ailleurs d'une
certaine manière la russie ça remonte
trait aux arts pierre le grand qui est
le fondateur de l'empiré russe ou au
début du xviiie siècle et qui est le
premier art a quitté son pays et à venir
en europe occidentale
il veut moderniser la russie donc
s'inspirer de ce qui se passe au même
moment en prusse en france en angleterre
aux pays bas ou en italie et donc il ya
des ambassadeurs qui viennent et lui il
se met dans le dans la suite des
ambassadeurs et incognito il se fait
engager alors qui pour devenir
artilleurs en prusse ou sur les
chantiers navals aux pays bas et en
angleterre
ce serait ça au fond l'origine de la
culture de l'espionnage et du
renseignement
chez les russes à écouter toute façon
c'est en fait voilà ça c'est c'est
historique
il ya un hasard en souverain il ya les
co comme vous l'avez très bien dit bon
requis qui s'est hissée me incognito
dans ce qu'on appelait la rumba
ambassade en 797
ou la russie avait besoin de trouver des
alliés en europe et 7 cette mission
était conduite par d
des proches du zar mais lui il était là
incognito comme vous l'a justement dit
hébron il se fait artilleurs en prusse
charpentier dans les provinces unies
il était allé acheter des plants de
navires en angleterre et ça c'est quand
même incroyable
imaginez-vous en france un seul droit
qui comme ça et a passé pratiquement un
an incognito pour lé 8 même se rendre
compte où en était l'état de les hauts
niveaux de la technologie ou au niveau
des techniques c'est l'odeur lui-même
qui l'a fait alors effectivement on peut
penser que ça remonte à cette époque là
il faut pas oublier qu'après bon
lorsqu'on parle de renseignements il ya
les renseignements extérieurs mais les
renseigne ont aussi internes et
malheureusement le renseignement interne
ça peut être également des des polices
politiques et dieu sait si les russes
enfin la russie tsariste avait dépouillé
c'est vraiment forte
donc il ya une vraie culture après bon
s'est passé on apprendra enfin ils ont
eu deux espions qui la galerie de vous
présenter dans luck est assez
impressionnante
un mot sur les anglais parce que ça
remonte aussi loin chez eux et
d'ailleurs dans votre livre boîte où les
cessions dont vous parlez soissons
anglais sont soit en anglais soit rue
soit travail pour les anglais soient
travail pour les russes et parce que
c'est vraiment les l'origine ou
quasiment
mais non il ya laissé ses
et quand il s'appelle frankoual chine
gamme qui lui est à l'origine de
l'espionnage moderne et lui c'est un
anglais on va le voir d'ailleurs valoir
jean gamme
c'est totalement il est apparu
donc à une époque où l'angleterre
n'était pas la puissance qu'elle est
devenue après
le pouvoir de la reine elizabeth était
était quand même et attaquer et au
niveau intérieur et au niveau extérieur
l'intérieur c'est marie stuart
extérieur le grand ennemi c'est
l'espagne et toute la politique van tinh
gaza a été grâce aux renseignements
grâce à ses espions qui l'a envoyé un
peu partout de renforcer l' influence de
l'angleterre et de la protéger
alors de quoi petite histoire tout ceci
s'est fait sur sa cassette et notre
brave val single qui est mort deux ans
après la fin de l'invincible armada donc
il est au moins 7 cette satisfaction a
été pratiquement ruiné parce que c'est
lui-même qui pièce malheureusement huit
partants tout le système qu'il a mis mis
en place a disparu et les services
anglais ne seront réapparu événement en
tant que service que au début du 20e
siècle
alors vous le disait il ya eu également
cromwell oui oui alors qu'au moins elle
si vous voulez c'est un peu différent
lui aussi a repris un tout petit peu
cela le flambeau de vals hingham quand
cromwell et thériault pouvoir là on est
au 17e siècle à peu près bon
tout le réseau qu'elle ait mis en place
trois singles n'existait plus bien
entendu dont cromwell a reçu une
certaine politique par rapport à vals
hingham il en a beaucoup parlé il a
comme une communiqué n'oubliez jamais la
communication on me dit que les anglais
sont extrêmement forts en matière de
renseignement c'est une certitude il en
ouvre et culture ce qui est totalement
exact et qui provient aussi du fait que
tous tous tous les cadres des services
aux viennent de deux endroits oxford ou
cambridge
voilà donc si vous voulez ce qui
facilite les contacts lorsque lorsqu on
peut travailler lorsqu'on veut
travailler dans certains domaines mais
il ya également le faire savoir
cromwell l'a fait savoir donc est ce que
il a été aussi actif en matière de
renseignements qu'il a bien voulu dire
en fait au moins de l'allier il a fait
savoir
alors c'est la vraie différence avec les
français les français vous le racontez
ça commence avec lui sourit 15 avec ce
qu'on appelle le secret du roi et leurs
cibles secret du roi donc on ne le fait
pas savoir du tout vous raconter bien et
est par exemple le chevalier d'éon on
lui a consacré des films voilà à nos
espions les plus célèbres il travaille
pour le secret du roi il travaille pour
louis 15 le chevalier d'éon alors cette
auto souviens c'est qu'on ne savait pas
s'il était un homme une femme
en fait au moment de son autopsie on a
vérifié c'était bien un homme mais c'est
vrai qu'il a rempli des missions pour le
louis 15 habillé en femme notamment
russie d'ailleurs en allant espionner
catherine de oui oui non mais l'histoire
du chevalier du chevalier d'éon est
absolument incroyable
effectivement il a été envoyé par louis
15 auprès de la tsarine
il a bête parce que à l'époque la guerre
de sept ans à préparer et on avait
besoin d'alliances et en particulier des
russes qui étaient beaucoup plus proche
des onglets et donc toutes les
ambassades a échoué et finalement le
chat liaison est allé là bas sous le nom
de l'oea de beaumont donc et a réussi à
être auprès de lazzari hne et ces races
si vous voulez à sa proximité avec la
tsarine et tout son entourage qui
effectivement est bien les russes se
sont rapprochés de la monarchie
française
voilà après parce que c'est fantastique
a pris il revient il combat pendant la
guerre de sept ans avec son grade de
capitaine des dragons dont il était très
fier il est blessé on peut dire c'est
pratiquement un héros et un gros par
après à londres où il aura plein de
malheur mais où surtout il arrivera à
voir alors là il est évident d'hommes
il arrivera à voir les
il arrivait à subtiliser lors d'une
soirée fastueuse qu'il aimait bien donné
avec fox victuailles et surtout beaucoup
d'alcool ils arrivent à se constituer
les notes dans lequel
on voyait jusqu'où les anglais étaient
prêts à aller dans les concessions dans
ce qui sera le désastreux qu'il était de
paris donc c'est grâce à ça que les
français ont su jusqu'où ils pouvaient
aller alors ce traité de paris a été
désastreux
mais on peut imaginer que 107 ce
renseignement a mené par des eaux ont
envahi noter encore pire il ya il
s'habille bon il ya également
beaumarchais célèbre écrivain l'auteur
des noces de figaro qui lui travaille
pour le secret du roi mais du temps 2016
il ya d'ailleurs un film beaumarchais
dans lequel on voit beaumarchais avec le
chevalier d'éon yatching majster qui est
le l'espion de napoléon il va être très
important chaumeil ce terrain pour
napoléon le schulmeister est important
je reviens simplement parce que ces
essais c'est une petite erreur qu'on
fait souvent beau marché était dans le
secret du roi du temps de louis 15 et de
ce fait du roi a été dissous en 1774 par
8,16 à donc donc il ya eu plus de
s'offrir deux voies à l'époque et après
mais c'est vrai que louis saez a confié
eux
à beaumarchés des missions très
importantes la mérite notamment
mais après absolument alors en amérique
on aimerait que c'est un peu différent
c'est plutôt bon marché qui était un
partisan absolue de l'intervention
française
op des insurgés américains qui a fait un
lobbying d'enfer il n'était pas le seul
mais en fait il a fait de lobbying
auprès de louis saez pour qu on y aille
voilà et d'ailleurs il avait monté aussi
sur ses deniers propres une base une
société de couverture
s'appeler portalez rodrigues et dans
lequel il fournissait ils transportaient
des armes pour les insurgés américains
voilà au marché ils pourront revenir à
leicester oui c'est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement important d' extrêmement
efficace aussi en fait
napoléon et savary qui était sans un peu
son 100 m d'avoir la matière cherchait
quelqu'un sachant par les allemands pour
pouvoir soigner les autrichiens et donc
ils sont tombés sur ce film esther me
quitter qu'un badoit d'origine si bien
entendu parlait parfaitement allemand
est qui qui avait véritablement en
dénombre qualités pour devenir en étions
à ce moment efficace il ya un espion
dont j'ai appris l'existence en vous
lisant ces charles i cento pendant la
lys y est au pardon unifiée tôt pendant
la première guerre mondiale lui
souhaiter au plus sait-on exactement
pendant la première guerre mondiale
c'est au moment où les allemands
utilisent les premiers gaz toxiques dans
les tranchées les français veulent
absolument sans en connaître les
composants et pouvoir éventuellement
bombarder les usines qu'ils produisent
et c'est et c'est lui qui va trouver et
l'un et l'autre et à la suite de ce
renseignement très important on va on va
organiser le premier bombardement
stratégique au fond on envoie des avions
bombarder l'usiné qui produit le chlore
qui se trouvaient dans les gaz toxiques
que les allemands venait d'envoyer dans
les tranchées ça c'est vraiment
important et ce type va devenir un
écrivain un auteur de romans
d'espionnage célèbre on envoie un
certain nombre derrière moi et des
titres très accrocheur c'est juste après
la première guerre mondiale
voilà c'est un peu l'ancêtre de ian
fleming et deux jambes russes et 2 et de
john le carré
oui tout à fait d'ailleurs vous
remarquerez que son héros s'appellent
james nobody donc lui-même français y
prend comme modèle pour écrire c'est ses
oeuvres de fiction bain en anglais et
déjà dire beaucoup de choses
et alors il nous reste deux minutes
avant de faire une pause et ensuite on
verra tout cette galerie de personnages
que vous dressez dans votre livre
mais c'est vrai qu'après à partir de
lussier tôt il ya plus de français
quasiment dans cette histoire
alors est ce que c'est parce qu'on ne se
fait jamais prendre à part les études et
faux époux tu ranges en nouvelle zélande
mais qu'est ce qui fait que au fond il
ya très peu de héros du renseignement
français
mais j'allais dire il y en a pas
tellement d'américains non plus il ya
surtout des gens qui travaillent et il
ya des anglais il ya des russes il ya
tous ceux qui travaillent pour l'un ou
pour l'autre mais au fond il n'y a pas
de grandes figures de l'espionnage
américain par exemple il ya tout premier
qui est totalement enfin don dont le
visage est totalement inconnu nathanaël
qui avaient été envoyés par washington à
new york lorsque new york a été pris par
les anglais donc c'était un jeune homme
qui faisait partie d'un régiment de
volontaires qui a été pris de suite et
qui a été tué par les anglais bon et
c'est devenu un héros national sa statue
figure d'ailleurs à l'anglais le siège
de la cia également à washington
mais on n'a aucune peinture aucune image
de ce garçon c'est un il faut les
américains ne créent leurs vrais
services de renseignement comme amant de
la seconde guerre mondiale le reste est
célébré pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale avant ça il n'y avait pas de
services de renseignement américains la
cia prendra la suite pendant là pendant
la guerre froide
là aussi on a l'impression qu'il n'y a
pas de culture du renseignement au
départ alors tout à fait tout à fait
alors je vous rappelle ils ont eu à un
moment un service qui s'appelait la
bloque chambers la chambre noire qui est
qu'ils avaient un rôle de 2go voilà de
lecture de courriers diplomates etc et
et ça c'est issus à bien de la première
guerre mondiale et en 1929 il ya sur les
terres d'état qui nomique s'appelle
halloween stimpson et qui s'aperçoit des
sens de ceux de ce service et qui pousse
des cris d'orfraie remise en mai des
gentlemans ne lisent pas le courrier
d'autrui donc à lille supprimés donc
pour vous dire un peu
le renseignement comme s'était vu aux
états unis donc effectivement il crée on
en parlait pendant la guerre loi 16 mai
il le supprime
dès la fin de la guerre et n'ont pas
l'intention d'occuper un autre service
sauf que on est en 45 et ben c'est il ya
un transfuge soviétique s'appelle igor
budan coût qui est defect à ottawa et
qui est grosso modo va révéler tout le
travail effectué par les services russes
en particulier ce poids manhattan qui
était programme de construction la bombe
atomique
donc là on s'aperçoit que quand même
qu'on fasse les gens sont extrêmement
agressif et là pour le coup on est dans
la nécessité fait loi fort et en
services c'est comme ça que naît la cia
donc effectivement voilà ils ont plus le
temps et vous avez totalement raison
le renseignement n'est pas dans la
culture américaine non plus et quand
vous dites qu'il n'ya pas des roues
tout ça à eros et qui sait quelqu'un
dont on parle donc faut communiquer
dessus et ça se travaille
bon bon y'a si ça c'est vrai pour toutes
les périodes historiques
il ya des jambons
dont les exploits ne correspondent pas
tout à fait à ce que ce qu'ils ont bien
blanc fait mais on en fait des héros on
a besoin de héros c'est le cas
effectivement en bretagne parce que il y
a un vrai nourrit culture c'est le cas
également à russie voilà faut savoir que
le kgb et maintenant ils savent ce
qu'ils ont succédé en leur fait 1-1
c'est ce qui totalement inimaginable en
france par contre aux états unis en
france bon c'est pas le cas donc je vous
appellerai gens qui arrivent plus je
vous interromps michel guérin ont fait
une pause on se retrouve juste après et
là on va les voir tous les héros du du
renseignement
[Musique]
nous continuons notre émission avec
michel guérin qui publie chez mareuil un
dictionnaire renseigner de l'espionnage
et pour cause il a fait toute sa
carrière aux michel guerrière dans le
contre espionnage
alors voyons un peu là cette galerie de
personnages plus ou moins fascinant qui
se trouve dans votre livre
commençons par la plus célèbre c'est
mathari c'est drôle que notre affaire au
fond la sphère la plus connue de
l'espionnage au 20e siècle et notamment
par les français et je trouve ça
typiquement français c'est cette femme
magnifique strip teaseuse qui couche
avec avec plein de d'officiers d'attaché
d'ambassade de diplomate pour leur
soutirer des renseignements et qui
finira tragiquement fusillé par par
l'armée française en tant qu'espion elle
était nulle
si on en croit les allemands qui l'ont
formé oui
sont celles qu'il a formé le dis très
clairement n'est pas faite pour ce
métier elle est totalement nulle
bon le drap de matéri si vous voulez
c'est que les
les informations qu'elle a donné bon
parce que mon expression ses pilotes
ça n'avait absolument aucune influence
mais c'était une personne qui a voulu un
tout petit peu berner les services de
renseignement elle a très rapidement
compris que en leur donnant des
informations elles pouvaient pouvait
avoir de l'argent
donc vous pouvez continuer sa vie la vie
qu'elle avait avant la guerre parce que
mon mari lorsqu'elle arrive à paris cc
c'est au niveau du siècle elle est très
jolie fille qui me faisait en 1915 un
énorme à l'époque c'était énorme
voilà ce que faisait donc un succès fou
enfin le temps passe et bon le l'étoile
de matar y pallier un petit peu bon et
elle est recruté par les services
allemands justement la guerre est là
elle comprend que ben ça peut il permet
de retrouver son lustre d'antan son
lustre d'antan c'est quoi ces fréquentes
et bad et des officiers qu'elles adorent
à la vie elle-même s'est fréquenté les
beaux hôtels etc
donc voilà elle profite de ce truc là un
moment elle devient agent double tout
simplement parce que ben ça arrive à
tout le monde
elle tombe amoureuse d'un permis c'est
une très très très nombreux amants d'un
d'un capitaine russe et pour pouvoir le
rejoindre
elle demande sauf conduit aux français
donc le chef du deuxième tour euh
d'époque qui devait s'appeler dupont lui
dis ok mais move travailler pour nourrir
voilà comment elle devient agent double
mais bon encore une fois est la rue
berné les services en leur donnant des
informations remonte de très faibles
niveaux qu'elle recueillait seul ouvrier
est véritablement ça n'a pas influé sur
la guerre et d'ailleurs on peut penser
que les allemands voulaient s'en
débarrasser et compte par hasard
pourquoi ton tel parce que tout
simplement les français interceptent un
message de madrid message envoyé par les
allemands dans lesquelles il parle
d'elle ils ont fait un de leurs agents
et surtout les allemands emploient un
code qui venait à être cassée par les
français ils savaient que le code avait
été cassé par les français puisque ça
faisait une semaine qu'ils utilisent
notre code et la wii balance le message
que son matériel ancien code dont qui
devait bien s'imaginer que les français
aient interceptées et donc voilà
peut-être que les allemands ont préféré
que ce soient les français qui exécutent
mathari on va dire ça comme ça il
fallait qu'elle meure toute façon parmi
tous ceux qui ont un esprit rayant de
fleming qui était lui même un ancien des
renseignements britanniques
il y en a un auquel vous faites allusion
qui est effectivement moi aussi mon
préféré c'est du sco popov qui était
serbe qui avait été lui aussi qui avait
joué les agents doubles pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale qui est un type
formidable on va voir sa photo
ce serait lui qui aurait inspiré de
jeanne monde est alors pourquoi pas ce
que lui vraiment il cumule tout un stade
dans 10
il est séducteur il est très viril il
roule en voiture de sport et vous le
raconter en plus il joue au casino ayant
de fleming en a été témoin il l'a vu
jouer et gagner au casino ce serait ça
qui aurait donné ce l'idée à ian fleming
de faire de james bond un habitué des
casinos
oui et tout à fait et c'est même plus
que ça puisque il joue en fait qu'ils
étaient en mission à estoril au portugal
et d'après l'histoire d'apple région on
a faim il aurait joué l'intégralité de
ses frais de mission sus au baccarat
voilà seront coup il gagne et on
retrouve d'ailleurs cette scène dans
casino royale donc effectivement we hope
of a été un élément d'inspiration de feu
de fleming il y en a eu beaucoup dans
votre signe vous en citer pas mal dans
le livre il ya la tôle la toque la plus
célèbres du 20e siècle
la taupe c'est un roman de john le carré
mais il ya eu des vraies taupe c'est
gunther guillaume qui s'étaient
infiltrés
donc en jusqu'au plus haut niveau en
république fédérale allemande en
allemagne de l'ouest puisqu'il était
tout près de vie libre entre le
chancelier et c'est lui c'est ginta
guillaume et en se faisant arrêter qui
va causer la chine de willy brandt un
tout à fait et au buteur guillaume
faisait partie de deux de ses agents
qu'un maître espion mais vraiment maître
espion qui s'appelait markus wolf qui
était le chef de hp a donc le service de
renseignement extérieur est allemand
avait lancé sur l'allemagne de l'ouest
et
au niveau technique si vous voulez bien
c'est très bien fait alors gunther
guillamet et recruter parce qu'il avait
un petit passé nazi voir comme beaucoup
à l'époque donc les allemands de l'est
se servent de cela pour le recruter
gunther guillaume devient un communiste
convaincu et il part en mission en rfa
avec son épouse qui fait également
partie du même service et leur rôle
c'est de
de pénétrer le parti de duchamp
célébrante mais en commençant par la
base
donc il s'installe il commence par
vendre des journaux ils ont la cote et
c'est inédit de voile est fortement l'un
et l'autre chacun de son côté
dans les puits ils vont dans les les
la mouvance la plus extrême la plus
hostile aux allemands de l'est et aux
russes et puis bon il gagne gagnant
gagne petit à petit d
des places si je puis dire et à un
moment où guillaume à une opportunité de
de postuler pour un poste dans le ce
qu'on peu ce qu'on peut appeler le
cabinet de de willy brandt
donc il eu ce rôle poste même s'il ya un
moment où vous savez chaque histoire à
un moment les gens ont des chaleurs
c'est à dire que en fait dans l'es2 le
dossier des ânons de l'ouest
guillaume figurer parce que il avait
fait un voyage en allemagne de l'ouest
avec un organisme qui était connu comme
étant
un support bus du service est allemand
donc là c'est bon pour lui et puis se
trouve que bon voilà il se défend bien
et puis la personne qui avait fait cette
étude bon disparaît je crois qu'elle
meure etc
il s'en sort comme ça il a le poste et
qui lui permettra par la suite quand le
poste de 1,1 des postes de chargés
d'affaires de hollywood se libère il a
le poste et là bon ben c'est ce qu'on
connaît quoi vous avez fait allusion à
markus wolf qui est le maître espion
probablement à des types les plus
géniaux dans l'histoire de l'espionnage
au 20e siècle
markus wolf qu'on voit sur cette photo
quand il publiera ses mémoires et lui
c'est un juif allemand qui émigrent
racontez-vous en urss au moment de
l'arrivée au pouvoir d'un adolf hitler
au fournil et fond il est formé par les
soviétiques et il va revenir ensuite en
rda et dirigé l'espionnage est allemand
et ça va être extraordinaire il va
arriver à il va parvenir à véritablement
infesté l'allemagne de l'ouest de taupe
est allemand est tout à fait tout à fait
d'ailleurs son surnom c'est une niche à
voilà donc quand il était chez les
russes ont la pub marcus micha et ça lui
restait du tout le monde l'appelait
micha et lorsqu il est devenu donc de
chef du hb à faut quand même savoir
qu'au dessus de lui
bon c'était pas le lefranc amour
c'était bon ça allait pas très bien mais
il a toujours eu parce qu'elle était
extrêmement proche des soviétiques
il a toujours eu ça n'est toujours sorti
il est resté pratiquement jusqu'au bout
chef du hpa parce qu'ils avaient ce
soutien russe et ce type là oui il est
alors c'est exactement les deux lui
aussi fait partie d'une légende parce
que pendant très longtemps on l'appeler
l'homme sans visage
aucun service occidental n'avait une
photo de lui on a eu une photo de lui
très très tard donc on ignorait
totalement qu'il était d'ailleurs john
le carré dans ses romans le le défi car
là donc le rang échéant en fait c'est
markus wolf john carey a toujours dit
que non mais enfin bon
les spécialistes considèrent que ces
marques marde marin marque schott
mais l'image qu'il en donne est
carrément à l'opposé de ce qu'il eût
markus wolf du vrai voilà un qui
banquiers plutôt beau gosse vont quêter
des aspects de paul newman et c est en
tant que chef espion oui c'est quelqu'un
alors c'est lui qui a lancé tous ces
espions en allemagne de l'est de l'ouest
c'est lui qui a lancé ces fameux gros
mais aussi juliette c'est à dire des
jeunes hommes des jeunes hommes et des
jeunes femmes qui étaient formés bas
pour pour a fait rire la sympathie d'une
personne ne s'est opposé et donc des
drames puisque il ya eu des mariages et
puis un moment il faut bien se révéler
il faut bien expliquer assaf abu ou ou à
son mari que ben non on est un espion et
qu'on a besoin de renseignements bon ça
c'est pas toujours passer tout seul pas
totalement inondée à propos de top
pardon michèle dayras mais puisqu'on
parle de tout ça vous a jamais traversé
l'esprit
quand vous avez vu le arrivée au pouvoir
et surtout michael gorbatchev
on sait qu'il est très populaire à
l'ouest beaucoup moins en russie mikhaïl
gorbatchev arrive au pouvoir en urss en
en cinq ans il va arriver à ce que le
mur de berlin tombe les pays satellites
quitte le giron de l'urss le pacte de
varsovie se disloque qui se rejoignent
tous eu le temps en quelques mois ou en
quelques années
l'urss elle même fini par imploser et le
parti communiste se faire interdire
est ce que ça vous a jamais traversé
l'esprit que gorbatchev était peut-être
une taupe des services américains ou
britanniques d'ailleurs tout est
toujours possible
enfin l'aspect ce bon vous savez je
pense qu'une de ses qualités de ce
métier c'est que bon deux fois une bonne
imagination mais faut pas tomber non
plus dans la paranoïa personnellement
personnellement non je pense que c'était
le sens de l'histoire
union soviétique il ya eu la guerre
d'afghanistan qui véritablement leur a
fait beaucoup de mal
il avait perdu la guerre des étoiles
économiquement ce n'était pas ça
beaucoup de gens n'y croyaient plus
d'ailleurs descente automatique dehors
que tous les transfuges de c'était
pourquoi explique que bon il était
vraiment patriotes mais à un moment ils
sont dit non c'est plus possible
ce régime là ne ne peut pas continuer à
être servi donc voilà donc je mange
enfin je peux me tromper
tout est toujours possible mais non je
crois pas après c'est vrai que vu poser
cette question
vu le bilan jeudi qu'un agent de la cia
aurait pas fait mieux quoi autre ton peu
autres taux dont vous raconter le destin
tragique c'est elie cohen agents du
mossad qui lui va réussir à s'infiltrer
au plus haut niveau de l'état syrien
mais qui va être finir très très mal
puisqu'il sera pendu une fois qu' il est
démasqué par part grâce aux égyptiens
d'ailleurs il est des basques et il est
pendu en place publique damas et les
essais retransmis en direct à la
télévision
pourquoi est ce que le régime de damas
avait avait fait ça à l'époque qu'est ce
que c'était pour que les israéliens
puissent le voir eu eux aussi à la télé
oui alors ils ont fait ça sans doute
d'une part pour lancer un message aux
israéliens mais je pense que c'était
beaucoup plus destiné au niveau interne
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre qu elie
cohen avait fait très fort faut quand
même quand même se souvenir que il était
au mieux avec
1 le responsable des troupes spéciales
syriennes avec quelqu'un du ministère
des affaires étrangères et avec un
parent du du président de l'époque
il faut également bien savoir qu'il
avait fait connaissance dans sa période
si vous voulez de légende c'est à dire
qu'aller en argentine comme
quelqu'un d'origine syrienne mais qui
avait fait fortune dans les ports export
et en argentine il y avait à l'époque
millas port assyrienne assez importants
dont le futur président amin
elle a fait ce bond et lorsqu'ils
arrivent en syrie babines à la fesse
devient résident donc il avait des
contacts énorme et vous savez il est oui
et il confié il confié à quelques
personnages que j'ai cité son
appartement et leur donner les clés pour
que ceux ci rencontrent leurs maîtresses
ce qu'il ya de fantastique c'est qu'il
avait son poste émetteur juste à côté
donc voilà et je pense que sa chance à
l'historien ont voulu ont voulu voilà de
donner une image forte de la répression
de la punition qu'ils infligeaient à ce
garçon qui d'ailleurs a été opéré et a
eu une petite faute à un moment il y les
repérer parce que ils commis trop trop
tout le temps au temps et aux mêmes
heures
ben on est là bien entendu bons services
syriens bien aidé par les soviétiques à
l'époque
bompard l'espoir de trigonométrie bon il
il arriva à localiser
l'émetteur est donc c'est comme ça
qu'ils prennent en flagrant délit en
plus
elie cohen entre elle et m alors il y en
a il ya quand même man américain qui est
célèbre
c'est francis gary powers mais c'est pas
vraiment un espion lui c'est un pilote
qui pilotait les avions espions de
l'époque les u2 on le voit ici c'est le
plus jeune celui qui est à droite
francis gary powers
il se fait abattre sud l'union
soviétique en 1960 au lieu de se
supprimer
parce qu'il avait sa plastique de
cyanure il n'en fait rien il se il saute
en parachute il est arrêté il est jugé
et son et son procès est retransmis à la
télévision tout le monde doit le savoir
c'était la preuve que les américains
espionné l'urss à l'époque donc grâce à
ces avions qui volaient très très haut
et qu'il était très difficile de voir
francis garnier pas voir s'il est un peu
oublié aujourd'hui mais à l'époque son
ç'avait été retentissant 1 écoutez en
termes diplomatiques oui parce que là
les américains été pris la main dans le
sac est bon là il vous pouvez y pouvait
rien dire
ils ont essayé de nier que mais ça a
tenu très peu de temps quelques jours la
prison comme jeu de reconnaître c'est un
avion espion qui avait été vous que
récupéré pratiquement intact et puis et
puis on l'a donc diplomatiquement
parlant est bon oui c'est un échec
alors la petite histoire aussi rigolote
de power c'est que quand il est repéré
par l'adc la rue c'est en premier mais
c'est au dessus de yekaterinburg et ya
un feu d'artifice et les spectateurs
pensent que les obus qui monte et qui
explose parce que ils arrivent à
atteindre les avions deux avions
d'ailleurs
eh bien il pense que c'est ça fait
partie de ce spectacle surtout qu'ils
voient descendre deux parachutistes gary
powers donc il s'éjecte en parachute
mais également l'autre avion qui
touchait qui en fait un mig russes
qu'ils avaient pris en chasse et qui est
touché par ça c'est parce à dessert et
donc le russe descend avec ça fait deux
parachutistes et les gens pensent que ça
fait partie du spectacle
bon voilà il va falloir ce qui est un
garçon qui a payé il va faire 18 mois 17
18 mois de prison
et puis il est échangé à l'époque on
échange les espions de chaque pays sur
ce fameux pont entre entre berlin et
postdam qu'on appelle le pont des
espions on le voit juste derrière moi ça
vous est arrivé d'y aller vous vous êtes
allé voir le pont des espions michel
guérin je ne suis pas allé non gelée vue
je les vends photo jeudi en film et
cetera mais bon ça sera peut-être
l'objet de futures vacances peut-être
non je vais pas vu mais c'est vrai que
mon cerveau mythique pour pour cette
période deux du renseignement
alors il ya une autre américaine dont
vous parlez c'est valérie plame
l'histoire de valerie plame elle est un
cran vraisemblable puisque ce tuer c'est
tuer la partie à la cia et son mari qui
est un ancien ambassadeur c'est lui qui
va révéler le scandale des fausses armes
de destruction massive de saddam hussein
argument qui avait été utilisée par
l'administration bush pour envahir
l'irak je parle de george w bush a pas
de son père qui lui était un ancien
patron de la cia mais qui était
peut-être un peu plus malin
en tout cas c'est le mari de valérie
plame qui révèle le truc et
l'administration bush va carrément
dénoncé sa femme en tant qu agent de la
cia
ça s'était jamais vu qu'un état un pays
dénoncent ses propres agents enfin ses
propres aux espions selon votre langage
puisqu'un agent c'est ce qu'on recrute
c'est pas le haut fonctionnaire qui
travaillent c'est une première ça s'est
jamais reproduit depuis
non mais écoutez évidemment espérant que
ça ne se reproduise jamais est ce que le
minimum que qu' il est officier de
renseignement et comme tout agent de
l'état d'ailleurs et qu'en droit
d'entendre de l'état qui l'emploie c'est
une protection et en l'espèce la
protection prises officier de
renseignement s'est là l'anonymat bon
d'ailleurs
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
ces réprimée par la loi en france et est
tenu par la loi de révéler l'identité
d'un officier de renseignement ou
travaillant dans un service de
renseignement
bon eh ben la voilà évidemment on ne
saura jamais exactement qui a fait
fuiter la chose mais ça vient très
clairement de l'administration bush et
en termes de déontologie c'est
absolument à 3,6 catastrophique et alors
dernier dernier cas il ya quelqu'un
qu'on a oublié je voulais absolument
l'avoir c'est celle qu'on a considéré
comme la mata hari du 21e siècle
anna chapman on va la voir en photo
c'est pas là où elle est la plus belle
il ya d'autres photos d'elle si vous
allez sur internet vous même parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une affluence euse
un en russie et les très célèbres
et elle elle s'est fait arrêter c'était
quoi en 2000 une dizaine d'années à peu
près s'est pas arrêté aux états unis où
elle avait monté une société
d'immobilier internationale et l a été
on a révélé que c'était une espionne
russe et que c'était la mata hari du 21e
siècle
reste qu'elle était meilleure espionne
que mata hari oui oui oui oui nettement
nettement d'abord à n'était pas seule
elle faisait partie d'un réseau un
réseau d' illégale que les russes
avaient implanté aux états unis avec un
parcours illégal normale est bon on sait
pas trop les informations qu'elle a
donnée c'est encore trop récent mais
pour le savoir
non elle a vraiment travaillé
sérieusement elle a une formation on ne
peut plus sérieuse c'est une illégal
donc vous voulez le nec plus ultra de la
formation des officiers de renseignement
et bon ben voilà
à l'issue d'une très longue enquête le
fbi qui a d'ailleurs appelé ça le les
illégaux ils sont pas cassé la tête
c'était programme des idées go donc ce
réseau ils ont appelé les illégaux la
été arrêtée et elle a eu la us cette
explosion médiatique a commencé aux
états unis commence et on lui a donné
effectivement tous les qualificatifs
aussi inimaginable
c'est une personne fort fort
intéressante au niveau de son physique
et qui a été accueillie à pascal a été
échangé elle aussi qui a été accueillie
en russie comme bon compte comme un
héros bon ben maintenant une influence
euse anna chapman en plus elle a une
plastique qui fait que un bon pour une
fois pour une fois bon voilà on a une
vraie espionne qui correspond un peu
aucun nom que l'on s'imagine en
regardant cette oeuvre de fiction
voilà pour finir les époux rosenberg
alors moi je suis trop jeune et sans
doute views vous aussi mais dans les
années 50 les époux rosenberg qui était
accusée d'espionnage en faveur de
l'union soviétique par les américains en
pleine guerre froide au moment où l'anti
communisme est absolument délirant aux
états unis voilà c'est ce couple avec
des petits enfants qui est accusé
d'espionnage au profit de l'union
soviétique
ça va être médiatisé dans le monde
entier il va y avoir des des pétitions
des manifestations en faveur des
rosenberg les rosenberg ne sont pas
coupables ils vont finir tous les deux
sur la chaise électrique ça va être un
drame terrible à l'époque
aujourd'hui on dit que les causes les
rosenberg en fait été coupable qu'est ce
que vous en pensez vous écoutez moi je
crois ce que je lis bon il ya
effectivement des documents est ce que
savait le fût de renseignements tous
aussi et secrète où tu te les garder
mais le temps passant
des documents sorte et en l'espèce en
russie maintenant et avant l'union
soviétique avec tout le chamboulement
qui a eu il ya pas mal de d'informations
qui sont sortis bon et ces informations
qui sont sortis
dise clairement effectivement que les
époux rosenberg étaient des officiers de
renseignement après sur l'impact qu'ils
ont eu bon ça effectivement on peut en
discuter
c'était pas forcément de l'est il
faisait partie à l'époque de d'un réseau
soviétique dont le but était de
travailler ce fameux programme manhattan
on déjà parler donc la construction de
la bombe atomique américaine et anglaise
voilà donc le rôle qu'ils ont eue ne
méritait certainement pas à la mort
après d'être relativement oui c'était
bien là la bombe atomique la première
que les russes vont acquérir pour vous
elle et elle vient des renseignements
qu'ils réussissent à obtenir sur le
projet manhattan notamment d'un
physicien qui s'appelle klaus fuchs dont
vous parlez dans votre livre
sans ces renseignements il n'aurait pas
eu la bombe atomique si vite
les soviétiques à l'époque en feuilles
staline en particulier or et c'est très
difficile de répondre à cette question
parce que si on n'a pas les éléments
mais on peut penser effectivement que ça
les a ça les a aidés
c'est le but si vous voulez d'espionnage
singulièrement l'espionnage industriel
et technologique
c'est de pouvoir produire beaucoup plus
vite voilà de gagner dé gagner des
années de recherche qui coûte le plus et
qui prend le plus de temps
et en l'espèce effectivement on peut
penser que oui ça les a formés
on peut le penser dernière question
michel guérin est ce que ce n'est pas un
problème le fait que tous les anciens
patrons des renseignements maintenant
publie des livres
je me souviens que c'était en france
quasiment tous les tous les patrons de
la dst se sont mis à publier des livres
leur mémoire aux états unis lé patron de
la cia publient leur mémoire on a vu
tout à l'heure markus wolf publier ses
mémoires on l'a vu en photo c'est pas un
problème à la fin alors écouter des
chants
je pense pas que tous les anciens
directeurs j'ai bien sans mémoire j'en
ai connu un certain nombre et publier
des mémoires
loin de là déjà ça commence comme ça il
y en a eu
après alexis gauche l'avait fait avant
lui constantin comment s'appelait-il
j'ai oublié son nom qui a des sous sous
pompidou women des kim mais le 10 mai il
s'était le conseiller sécurité du
général de gaulle donc lui n'a nagé me
diriger un service reprendra enfin bon
il chapeaute et tout ça donc c'est vrai
et c'est vrai que roger wybo le premier
est d accord la dst a également publié
des mémoires non ils sont pas si
nombreux que ça après bon en général
alors il y a deux cas de figure soit
certains peuvent régler leurs comptes ou
refaire entre l'histoire l'enfer comme
tous les gens qui publient des mémoires
c'est ma meuf mais la plupart du temps
moi je prends en général et pour les
américains et pour les anglais aussi
qu'ils ont écrits et également pour les
quelques français ils sont conscients
que ça qu'ils ont écrit
ça peut ce sont des gens sérieux en
général et ça peut permettre
singulièrement en france 2 de faire
comprendre aux gens que le renseignement
on voit c'est pas aussi aussi monstrueux
que ça que c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important et même
indispensable donc ça peut profiter à
l'acquisition d'une culture de
renseignement en france dont on a besoin
et qui manque à l'heure actuelle bon
encore une fois ça procès on en a parlé
en début d'interview mais voilà donc non
bonsoir ça me choque pas plus dès lors
bien entendu dès lors qu'ils ne révèlent
rien d'opérationnel voilà diamant entre
publie libos raconte d'abord c'est de
mémoire sur le titre de ce rêve c'était
mon probable pour la dst donc il
expliqué comment il avait fallu qui se
bat pour imposer à diest et cetera ok
d'accord mais dès lors que vous ne
parlez pas d'une affaire opérationnelle
et qui peut encore avoir des
conséquences actuelles
bon voila merci michel guérin d'avoir
participé à cette émission je rappelle
que vient de paraître chez mareuil votre
dictionnaire renseigner de l'espionnage
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
oui